all right it's Thriller night but your
dress is Mario I love it I love it uh
tell me about your costume because I saw
you and your girlfriend were dressed as
the characters from Super Smash Brothers
so uh during the pandemic my girlfriend
and I got really into Super Mario
Brothers and it was a really cool
activity to do and we just figured we've
been going on this theme of like
matching costume so why not it made
sense that's a good couple's theme
that's a good one listen this is a big
night because of course not only are we
celebrating 40 Years of Thriller but
this is for such an important cause talk
to me about tonight so it's an honor to
be here like I can't be getting
expressed that enough to celebrate 40
Years of the best-selling album of all
time incredible
[Music]
plus we're here for a good cause we're
here for two foundations the hill Los
Angeles foundation and the DD Jackson
Foundation both of them work with
children uh the DD Jackson Foundation
specifically works with grieving and
people who have lost a parent or a
significant person in their life the Los
Angeles Foundation is uh around
education and really trying to improve
the quality of life through education of
both soft and hard skills and this is
our kind of annual fundraiser so we've
been so so fortunate so blessed to be
able to raise as much money as we have
to fund our programs we have our second
year of both our programs a virtual
cooking class and a fitness clinic and
we're about to open up our third program
which is in the mental health space it's
probably starting next year I can tell
this is a labor of love for you by the
smile on your face when you're talking
about this I mean how much preparation
goes into a big event and night like
this every year uh we start planning
probably next weekend so we've been
planning this since November of last
year the 4 40th anniversary is a really
big Monumental achievement and it's just
something that we really wanted to
really do it right if you know what I
mean so we my team and I and they all
have just as much love and passion as us
this is truly a team effort and it's
it's just so exciting it's so exciting
let me ask you this knowing the mission
of these foundations specifically heal
La what message you have for kids out
there who might be struggling themselves
with the loss of their parent
that's tough that's tough yeah I mean
it's still a process for me a grieving
process and a journey that I've been on
and I don't think that any one way is
right you have to do what makes you feel
good and whatever helps you deal with
the loss of someone that you loved
significantly absolutely and that's
unfortunately that's the best advice I
can get life continues to go on and it's
beautiful and you kind of live out their
legacy though by doing stuff like this
exactly exactly as long as you celebrate
them they're never gone
[Music]
foreign